à la saint valentin
s'il te tiens la main ils vont la sainte
marguerite mais pour l'instant c'est
pour la saint-valentin joyeuse saint
valentin
[Musique]
souley
tu vraiment magnifique s'asseoir j'avoue
que tu es radius
c'est peut-être un éclairage jeune
demoiselle recherche un mec mortel
c'est pas les critères ou briques t'as
aucune chance vas y fonce
t'aurais pas comme une envie de me
violer commence à me déshabiller
c'est comme ça toi ou copié du tout
j'aime bien normalement et selon les
statistiques je devrais rencontrer un
garçon de mona jouent à peu près
normalement je devrais le rencontrer là
où je travaille
aux yeux tu sais tu veux pas qu'on dise
tout de suite je commence à avoir des
fourmis de seconde taxe coûté boulot
boulot toit des cheveux naples à st sour
s'il me plaît son intestin grêle dans
play je t'aime où es-tu les murs avec
moi dans le nord-pas-de-calais
oui nous quelque chose de sale
[Musique]
le bas
qui l'amour c'est pas juste un sentiment
c'est aussi se raser les burnes quoi
faire le bon choix
où es tu pue de la gueule vos chaussures
tu t'es pétron c'est pareil kacou et
très tendre oui je tente
j'aime bien donner mais j'aime bien
savoir aussi
je te
ça tombe bien j'ai un gros gros show de
la [__] tu sais quoi je vais te casser
tes petites pattes arrière goût
feuilleton polochons
une joyeuse
oh
[Musique]